this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 43 Echo Charles sitting here with
me we had a false start momentarily oh
good a second ago I read the wrong
number I said the wrong number it wasn't
even close this is 43 I said what 32.
imagine where my mind is Imagine where
my mind is that I'm thinking 43 and I'm
saying 32. I think yeah it's hard for a
brother even the strongest have their
moments of fatigue maybe you're just a
little bit I don't know we've been we've
been podcast recording today for five
hours at this time
yes sir okay so
you recently mentioned to me the
possibility of
the Charles
family unit
acquiring possibly a dog a canine so I
figured this is a good opportunity to
discuss real quick because we got some
really good questions just understanding
theoretically and pragmatically dog
ownership okay okay so
I have a dog
um I want to make sure that you and
everybody kind of knows this dogs are
work they are a lot of work
they are not only a lot of work
but they are a lot of responsibility and
as a dad with four kids that are now
older I'm gonna go on a limb here
and say that in some ways especially a
puppy in some ways a dog is
the same kind of responsibility as a kid
in some ways
uh you know you have to feed them you
have to walk them they never grow out of
that phase like eventually your kid can
go to the bathroom right yeah your dog
never learns how to use the toilet yeah
right that's not happening so you have
to be home you have to go home they
can't get out if they need to get out
now you get a dog door I have a dog door
by the way yeah digital electronic like
yeah like they're caught my dog's collar
opens the little gate oh damn so if he
needs to go to the bathroom we're good
food if you want to travel
this is probably the biggest adjustment
if you want to travel we have kids you
take the kid with you yeah right with a
dog that's not necessarily possible yeah
right you got to get a crate if you're
taking it on a plane or in the car or
certain hotels you can't say there's a
bunch of issues you can't just leave it
at home you can't you can hire like a
house sitter but then you're hiring a
house sitter right there's a lot of
things I'm saying you got to think about
that there's a lot of responsibility
there's a lot of work by the way you
have to train this
individual you you you have to train the
dog just like you have to train your own
children
and I know that sounds a little bit
twisted to say you're training your
children but you kind of are you are
never mind kind of
so before you just run out and buy a dog
because they're cute or whatever think
about the level of work think about the
level of responsibility now what are the
rewards some massive rewards number one
security
no better security than a dog criminals
do not like houses with dogs in them
they don't they're going to go away
they're gonna go to the next house
that's the that's the single biggest
deterrent for
crime for household crime for breaking
an entry is a dog so if you have a dog
even the little scrappy dogs like little
small dogs they're a deterrent just
because they're annoying right criminals
like this is too annoying I'm not going
in there if you have a dog like my dog
yeah that's what they turn yeah you're
deterred the whole neighborhood's kind
of deterred
uh and by the way if you're getting in
the dog game check out Mike ritlin's
information
read his book uh he's got a bunch of
great stuff on dogs I'm just giving you
my sort of
semi amateur I'm not I'm obviously not a
professional dog trainer like Mike but
I'm a professional dog owner sure
because I legitimately own a dog so you
have the security aspect which is
awesome you have the fun aspect because
dogs are fun
like they're just fun they're like a
little weird person that doesn't talk a
lot
but they give you looks they know what's
up like with my dog
if I just like turn my head quick my dog
goes in alert mode for real yeah and I
test him with it and I reward him so you
know I'll be sitting sitting down you
know working on something and all of a
sudden I'll just perk up and look and he
goes into alert mode he goes his ears go
up he's ready to go yeah
and that's kind of fun and plus they're
good to hang out with a dog yeah they're
they're super cool to you
they're nice
they they will go the run with you
they'll work out not necessarily do the
workout but they'll be in there and
chilling with you cruising like
participating in their own special way
yeah accompanying you to the workout for
sure uh
there's so something that's important
about all these things
is that discipline equals freedom so if
you have a dog that you train
then you're set then it's awesome if you
have a dog that you don't train and it's
just a wild animal on a leash
that sucks
my dog don't even need a leash I just go
for runs with him he stays with me if he
sees something or he's doing something I
don't want to do I can tell him stop
he'll stop like I'm talking cats you
know what I mean he will he listens to
me he doesn't for instance
there's a security Perimeter at my house
that he knows that he patrols and he
stays within the perimeter
uh so it's awesome so I was gonna not
say that because I didn't want a
criminal to think that they could stay
outside the security permit and be okay
but it's fine you can know that if you
cross the perimeter you're in trouble my
dog's gonna get you if you stay outside
okay you can stay out there unless I
release him then you're screwed
um
so discipline with a dog actually equals
Freedom which is awesome but you have to
put the time and effort into a dog
before you get one don't run out and buy
it just because it's cute they are a
pain
especially when they're puppies and then
even when they get older you gotta you
gotta deal with them you're responsible
for them so keep them on what kind of
dog are you considering getting we are
getting oh what's called and I never
heard of this dog even though I heard
I've seen them before it's called the
Basenji okay what that is no yeah me
neither but if you see them you'd be
like huh maybe I've seen that okay so
this is what it is it's the old you see
the what do you call them the
hieroglyphs or the the old Egyptian
writing on the wall you know the dog
that looks like a foxy right yeah
it's that
so when I see it I've seen pictures I
thought sure that's cute that's nice or
whatever you know they're they're
perfect for Basenji Basenji yeah
so um what do you name it
I was gonna kind of run those by you two
probably Zeta probably
um it's mainly for my daughter mainly
she was the main advocate for this move
I was against it I'm for it now because
we went and met him and all the stuff so
we went to I guess the the dad the dog's
dad is like a show dog like who won the
last like two years of the dog show that
they have here apparently I don't know
I'm just learning all this too so
they're really good like
you know the lineage or whatever is that
good but what I really liked about it is
like they're not super cumbersome you
know they're really nice yeah they super
friendly medium like
I don't know 30 pounds 40 pounds it was
a
18 and a half inches I think they said
okay so it's like it's medium medium
yeah so it's not like it was it was like
Yeah medium smart yeah yeah
extra media extra Furrow like to see the
full grown one I was like dang that's a
good looking dog but he seems a bit
small and he really just reminded me of
like a fox dog ish even the color is
like almost like a red but anyway really
nice super friendly like they don't I
think they're like quasi hypoallergenic
or whatever which was kind of the
criteria that my daughter kind of wanted
or whatever do they shed they shed like
once a year or something for like
seasonal or so or once or twice or
something like that
um
this is happening
this is happening how old is the dog
gonna be when you get it I don't know
three months maybe okay Jack all right I
could be wrong about that a little puppy
just know there will be added
responsibility which look I know I'm not
trying to be mean or whatever I'm not
trying to take a dig at you no no you
are but cool I know the added
responsibility is not something you're
usually looking at I don't pursue those
yes exactly right uh well the good news
is and the reality like I grew up with
with dogs more than one like I've had we
had one when we were super small where
my dad would take care of my mom and dad
take but even as just young kids all the
way up into adulthood we had two dogs
two Dalmatian dogs too which are
freaking hyper and whatever and I train
them oh I was kind of a tired but here's
the thing I was super disciplined and I
realized when you said this would be an
equals Freedom bro that's so true
because the more discipline you are like
you can actually be pretty like hardcore
with a dog as long as they're it's super
predictable they'll just totally listen
to you and you're right down for the
cause oh yeah fully they're just like
yeah yeah that's how
um and they were we let them inside
didn't you know they would shed a lot
which kind of sucks white hair
everywhere but they would listen though
like I taught them little tricks and
stuff and apparently they're super
Dalmatians anyway or
um what do you call they have high
energy or whatever so you might not be
able to train them as good bro they died
potty trained it like they would never
use a bathroom in the house ever
they'd always go to the door and be
scratching the door howling and stuff
trying to get out to use bathroom or
whatever you need that dog door yeah
this was back in from Kauai maybe
1992. I don't know either way I trained
them by myself
and so I know I know what it's like to
have a dog here but the traveling thing
is like that's the part and we're like
we gotta set up some criteria for where
they can go or whatever while we travel
yeah
so that part's probably the biggest
bummer in my opinion but otherwise I met
the dog and all that so I'm like all
right I dig it I see it now okay because
you're right and it'll get you know when
you have kids or whatever and my kids
are five and eight that's gonna get them
out of the house even more you know like
riding around with a dog and doing all
that stuff which I kind of want I'm
gonna be walking that dog and whatnot
and they can learn some responsibility
so I'm down for that for sure
um
all right should we get some question
yeah
might as well
all right first question Jaco
B that is a little excerpt of what we
are doing on the Jocko underground
podcast so if you want to continue to
listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground